stephen king
the king of horror is a master
storyteller
he's blessed or perhaps cursed the world
with terrifying content
books movies and tv shows he was born in
portland maine in 1947.
king's dad was mostly out of the picture
and his mom raised him and his older
brother
in what he described as an odd
herky-jerky childhood
moving around a lot his first prophet as
a writer
one whole dollar came from his mom he
continued to write through his
adolescence
publishing his first story about a
teenage grave robber in a comic book
fanzine
when he was a senior at university of
maine he wrote graveyard
shift which sold for 200
he met his wife and they got married
after college she took a job at dunkin
donuts
and he worked at a dry cleaner getting
by but barely
by this time they already had two
children and there would soon be more on
the way
finally he got a job as an english
teacher but continued writing novels as
much as he could
he started working on what would later
be kerry only to throw it in the trash
it was famously rescued by his wife
tabitha who urged him to finish the
manuscript
stephen listened to her and finished the
story which he then submitted to a
publisher
the paperback rights were sold for four
hundred thousand dollars
instantly changing his life the
manuscript would also be adapted for the
big screen
which did 33.8 million dollars when it
was released in theaters in 1976
the equivalent of 156.8 million dollars
today
it was the first of many stories that
would fuel nightmares
and shatter records
[Music]
many of these novels have been adapted
into movies as well as tv and streaming
series
with king doing the occasional cameo you
uh
want me to sign it for you nah i didn't
like the ending
over the last decade he sold more than
32 million copies of his books
with 11 22 63 being the best-selling
book
which was later adapted into a series on
streaming service hulu
steven and tabitha spend most of their
time in maine but head down to florida
during the winter
and if you can't wait to get your hands
on the next stephen king novel
you can kill some time on his twitter
page his random thoughts and musings are
entertainment gold
you